never waste a crisis every crisis is an
opportunity
one really valuable piece of advice that
I received was that companies are like
people they need a heartbeat
I need rhythms it gives people
continuity amiss kind of the craziness
of startup life if your earlier own
sound feeling telling they're late what
I've learned is that hard work really is
the great equalizer and as long as
you're putting in the time and effort
that's required then you're gonna see
results I think the best advice of God
is not to you know forget your life it's
really easy to say oh that's something
that's gonna happen someday and then you
find you know the accomplishments come
in and you know there's just another one
to shoot for and they wind your life
gonna start my mother told me kill
people with kindness and if I'm just
nice to everybody you get what you want
the young entrepreneurs you can be super
smart but you still may not have that
experience to grow the business of
hiring the best people to compliment
that lack of experience it's something
that's really important to grow up to
really grow up it's letting that image